مره اخرى يعود الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل الى واجهه المشهد السياسي ومعه ثلاث
منظمات مدنيه اخرى عبر اطلاق مبادرته انقذ
وطني كما سميت لايجاد مخرج مما يرونه ازمه
متعدده الاوجه ووضعا خطيرا يتهدد تونس لم
تنضج كل جوانب المبادره بعد ولكن شكلت
لجان لصياغه وثيقه توضح معالمها يقول
المبادرون ان الهدف المؤكد هو انقاذ تونس
لانقاذ الوطن
وبعد التشاور بعد ما وضع كل اللمسات
الاخيره بس يقع صياغه برنامج يكون متكامل
كان في كثير من العقلانيه في الاستقلاليه
الهدف الرئيسي اللي هو يربطنا هو كيفيه
انقاذ تونس تاتي هذه المبادره تزامنا مع
اطلاق منظمات اخرى واحزاب ونحو 30 شخصيه
ما سمته اعلان السادس والعشرين من جانفي
كما اعلنت في بيان لها العمل بكل الوسائل
السلميه لايقاف مسار الرئيس قيس سعيد لكن
هذه التحركات والمبادرات تواجه تحديا
اساسيا وهو نظره الرئيس المختلفه في توصيف
الوضع في البلاد مبادره الاتحاد
الوطني
السياق الاعتراف بوجود ازمه سياسي الرئيس
سعيد لا يعترف بمناسبه ويعتبر ان هذا كله
غير موجود وغير صحيح يعني بطريقه عاديه
تعبير عبر محاكمه المدنيين امام القضاء
العسكري
على حد وصفها في ما يمضي الرئيس في تنفيذي
مشروعه حيث يجري يوم الاحد الدور الثاني
للانتخابات التشريعيه التي لم تشهد اقبالا
في دورها الاول
انما تتعمق الازمه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
يوما بعد يوم في تونس لا يبدو مخرج من
المازق السياسي الراهن قريبا بين معارضه
تحاول جمع شتتها ورئيس يواصل مساره غير
عابئ بمنتقده حافظ مربح الجزيره تونس